قلت ما هي النقابات التي ترعى وتدعو لهذه
الاحتجاجات
كل النقابات عبد القادر كل
النقاب مي عن الكونفدراليه الفرنسيه
الديمقراطيه للعمل واسماء اخرى كلها تشترك
في نقابه العمل او نقابه العمال او القوه
القوه العماليه الى اخره على الاقل ثلاث
نقابات رئيسيه تدعم هذه تدعم هذه
التحركات وهذه المظاهرات من بينها ايضا
النقابات الخاصه بعمال القطاع النقلي
السككي اضافه الى الى نقابات الطلبه
الطلبه الجامعيين وطلب الثانويين فدخول
هذه النقابات الطلابيه على الخط بشكل اكبر
وتعطيلها وسدها لمنافذ الجامعات وغلقها
لثانويات وجامعات قد اعطى النقابات
العماليه قوه وزادها بين قوسين شرفا بان
تدخل هذا المعترك ضد الحكومه في بمعنى انه
هناك اجماع نقابي على تحريك الشارع ضد هذا
القانون مثل ما هناك اجماع حكومي داخل
السلطه لدعم هذا هذا المشروع
المشاركه بالارقام في باريس
عاده تعطى في نهايه في نهايه المطاف وتصدر
كالعاده النقابه تعطي رقم والسلطات
الامنيه تعطي رقم عاده يكون تكون الارقام
متقاربه ولكن في الغالب تكون يعني متباعده
كل يعطي رقمه والشارع يبقى تبقى يعني يبقى
مستعدا لخوض معترك جديد وخوض معركه جديده
بعد خمسه ايام وقد تكون بعد اسبوع وسيسمى
ذلك اليوم اليوم الحادي عشر الاكبر